klingon narration
there are many things i enjoy about the
kelvin timeline but the revised look of
the klingons is not one of them
and yeah yeah i know discovery's not
technically said in the kelvin timeline
but it's using the same look so it's an
apt comparison get off my back
this drought's gonna last 89 years
technology is so advanced that they can
see into the future i'm just gonna say
it i think that's total bull
if we don't do something now they won't
live another thousand hours the ambient
radiation from a nearby meteor drilling
accident dried out their water table
but the captain would surely already
know this information since that's why
they're down here so why would michael
be repeating this to her i get it so we
know why they're on the planet but come
up with a more creative way to divulge
that info to us
these new gun models have a avoid the
walls of the well perfectly setting and
honestly it was a great upgrade choice
storm is moving faster than i thought
guess she didn't calculate for the
ever-changing winds of plot convenience
rookie mistake avoid contact to comply
with general order one but also remain
in plain sight so your interference is
obvious
i'm grateful captain but you'd be more
grateful if your captain had reminded
you to use the protective gear around
your head to protect you from the sand
right cover your mouth these are our
footprints
you've walked us in a circle not exactly
a circle
michael is smart very smart she'd have
known while walking this shape that they
weren't creating a circle
also given how the wind is blowing and
the ship is descending leaving visible
footprints in the sand would be truly
difficult
we don't usually send the opening
credits at least not for actually being
opening credits but when you're dealing
with a franchise that has had some very
famous and exciting examples in the past
it's hard not to notice how
underwhelming these are
i'm not saying i missed faith of the
heart but i'm closer to missing it than
i would like to be
first officer's log start a 1207.3
main line of star trek episode opens
with a log entry cliche
any idea what it is a very strange
interpretation of an updated starfleet
uniform look at these leg zippers what
is the use of these decorative thigh
zippers
i have plenty of thoughts most of which
revolve around how much [ __ ] talking
there is in the show
maybe the budget is limited and the
effects are hard and stuff but can we
please be
shown something instead of being told to
death on behalf of captain georgio and
the entire crew of the uss shenzhou we'd
like to welcome you to flight 819
airplane humor commencing final
pre-launch system checks
life support nominal oxygen nitrogen
saturation
nominal announcing ship status and
ungodly amounts of techno babble might
be a beloved star trek staple but the
show isn't getting off that easy it's
still getting the this goes on for some
time sin because that
is a beloved tv sin staple boost signal
unable to comply
i can understand trying to get
communications back online but nobody
should be acting surprised that this
happened
communication failure was literally part
of the conversation before the mission
started
as gorgeous as this shot is i can't help
but hear all of the parental figures
telling me to never look into the sun
because i could lose my vision
and sure they have to have special
coding on these visors to make any of
this make sense but still
don't look directly into the [ __ ]
star you'll catch a cold it won't make
unless we get her back now
except you don't get her now and she
does make it so i will volunteer you to
wear the red shirt in the next episode
you spelled wheaton wrong hang on more
like floated out but
semantics awful nice of the debris to
leave her alone now that her suit isn't
operational
i once had a friend toby who spoke
klingon and had one of the swoopy knives
on his wall he said that when a klingon
dies the bodies are meaningless because
of their warrior beliefs or some
i hate myself for remembering that but
he would not shut up about his obsession
i haven't seen toby in 20 years but i
can hear him screaming at his television
from here so thank you discovery for
[ __ ] up klingon lore for toby i honor
you with a sin
jeez if this coffin porn goes on for
much longer i'll be watching it from the
comfort of my own
steven summers star trek
ah it's funny because a lot of people
say the reavers from firefly are
rip-offs of klingons and here star trek
is ripping off the reavers adorning
their ships with dead bodies i believe
that's also known as the circle of life
david cronenberg star trek do you
understand the effect of genetic
unspooling
yeah but just in case that one guy in
the background doesn't understand you
can go ahead and explain to him while
i'm standing close
i mean i could explain it to you but you
seem really passionate so
if there are klingons in this sector we
should withdraw immediately
this is federation space retreat is not
an option
few things here what's up with this
finder's keepers [ __ ] from the
federation they can't allow an alien
ship to even hang out in this space
sure whatever it is may have picked up
the communicator but they don't know
this
also i understand the captain is brave
and all but have they ever been in
battle in this ship
certainly not against klingons right and
their second in command is gravely
injured so why would they not
fall back tell starfleet their foot and
then come back for the attack
i just feel like this shocking klingon
ship reveal is lost because this guy's
eyes are always wide open
is he surprised afraid wondering if he
left the food maker thingy on
impossible oh shut up robot face you
should have the red alert warning on
your face and you know it
and this does happen the beacon is lit
gander calls for aid rohan answers but
what really confuses me is how the
klingons could see the light in the
first place
in lord of the rings there's a physical
fire snaking through the mountains in
space the light explodes and they must
travel incredible distances to reach the
destination
anyway lord of the rings is better
here's a fan service sin for those of
you who are pissed that this form of
holographic communication wasn't
invented until later
and this in is for not just sitting back
and enjoying a new show's interpretation
of technology
optical sensors that's okay this ship
has old earth tech just laying around
and is surely equipped with sun shades
it seems to be some sort of signal
emitter
or they're just about to take a picture
and accidentally have the flash on maybe
don't walk into the room and immediately
blurt out whatever you
think you know michael where are my
filters see
it is for a picture permission to leave
the bridge captain are you kidding it's
relevant is is that code for michael
having started her period
computer working since when do we need
computers to reply with working
what happened to the little ding i don't
need my smart speaker to reply
yeah what's up just make a trippy beep
so i can ask random trivia questions and
let's get on with it
amanda byrne hello saric man that was
quick
are vulcans just always on the ready
never playing golf or on the toilet
reading maxim
captain we have to give the klingons a
vulcan hello
roll commercials
i'm sorry sorry in advance but [ __ ] the
vulcan neck pinch
i feel like this is the franchise's get
out of jail free card when they can't
come up with any other [ __ ] way to
get out of a situation it's star trek's
very own this works
also michael isn't falcon and yeah yeah
she trained on vulcan and has some kind
of past with sarak but in star trek 3 it
was made very clear that humans aren't
able to deliver an effective vulcan neck
pinch so this series pretty much gives a
big middle finger to continuity
i don't understand warp and beacons but
it seems that if the klingons were
scattered around and starfleet is
organized starfleet could have been
present far before the klingons would
arrive
of course then there wouldn't have been
a cliffhanger and if there's not a
cliffhanger who'd want to watch the next
episode immediately available
if you're a subscriber
this is not combat it's an act of
lunacy general sir personally i think
you're a [ __ ] idiot
do the cinemasins guys secretly love
movies have they had a podcast devoted
to discussing movies
called scentcast since 2015 have they
had a vast array of movie talks deep
dives games guest interviews q a and
much more on the scene cast damn it i
said keep it down
screw it the secrets out check out the
scene cast every monday and more
wherever you do your podcast we have fun
we come
in peace and you go in pieces
[ __ ] one proton torpedo in that small
exhaust port and the whole thing goes
blammo
this is not gonna last much longer hang
on
explore do you do copy
[Music]
how did the vulcans achieve diplomatic
relations with the clintons
there's an old vulcan proverb only
nixon could go to china you don't like
me bombed you don't like my methods
you think i'm an accountant
oh you gotta be kidding me